[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend das ist den
Klimawandel gibt bestreitet so gut wie
niemand das ist ein Umdenken und einen
Umbau bei unserer Energieversorgung
braucht auch nicht wenn es dann aber ans
Eingemachte geht also ans umsetzen dann
haben wir das das liegt am Unwillen des
ein oder anderen Bürgers an Kampagnen
die falsche Informationen verbreitet
haben und auch an der misslichen
beschlechten Kommunikation der
Verantwortlichen in Berlin und während
auf der großen politischen Bühne aktuell
ja weniger gestritten aber immer noch
gerungen und angepasst wird wird ein
anderer Stelle gemacht es gibt
Bundesländer die dem wärmeplanungsgesetz
vorgreifen und bereits mit dem Umbau bzw
Ausbau ihrer heiz-infrastruktur begonnen
haben Diana zimmermann
während sich die Republik über das
heizungsgesetz Soft sitzen die meisten
in Rostock auf der warmen Zuschauerbank
denn die Stadt hat einen gut ausgebautes
Fernwärmenetz das Uwe Hempfling aus dem
Umweltamt noch größer machen möchte wir
haben noch nicht alle Bürger
angeschlossen und wir sind bemüht das
fernwärmen jetzt schnellstmöglich
auszuweiten das braucht natürlich ein
paar Jahre wir gehen davon aus dass wir
bisher dass wir ca 4 km pro Jahr das
Fernwärmenetz ausbauen können momentan
versorgen 800 km Rohre 60% der Rostocker
Haushalte mit Wärme in ganz Deutschland
sind es bislang nur 8% der Haushalte
einzelne Ballungsgebiete im Ruhrgebiet
und den östlichen Bundesländern erregen
inzwischen den Neid der anderen wir
stellen einen kompletten
Paradigmenwechsel fest äh die Leute
bestimmen die sowohl die Stadt als auch
die Stadtwerke mit der Frage wann kommt
die Fernwärme
der Vorteil liegt auf der Hand wer an
zentrale Fernwärmenetz angeschlossen ist
hat keiner heizungssorgen mehr wie Kohle
und Gas ersetzt werden ist dann das
Problem der Kommunen laut Gesetzentwurf
zur kommunalen wärmeplanung müssen die
in den nächsten Jahren ihren
Energiebedarf ermitteln und auf
CO2-freie Energieträger umstellen
deswegen ist die Verknüpfung zwischen
wärmeplanung und GG so wichtig dass die
Menschen wissen okay ich bin in einem
Bereich wo zum Beispiel eine zentrale
Wärmeversorgung geplant wird darauf kann
ich mich einstellen und dann gibt es
auch eine Übergangsfrist zum Beispiel
für den Einsatz von fossilen Heizungen
bis dann die zentrale die karbonisierte
Wärme da ist doch das GEG das Gebäude
Energiegesetz kam zuerst und mit ihm
große Verunsicherung der Bürger heftiger
Streit um teilweise vielleicht unnötige
Wärmepumpen zu schnell zu viel so die
Kritik an der Regierung wir machen die
Politik mit viel zu viel schaumvermutzen
immer alles ganz schnell gehen wir
müssen es gut machen gut gemacht ist
besser als schnell und schlecht und das
gilt auch für die wärmeplanung und es
ist ja mit der Planung nicht getan die
Kommune muss dann Überlegen haben wir
eine Chance ein Fernwärmenetz zu bauen
ein Nahwärmenetz zu bauen und das sind
riesige Investitionen und da muss man
auch überlegen wer finanziert das wie
und welche Zeit brauchen wir dafür so
einige Länder und Kommunen waren
allerdings viel schneller als Berlin
Rostock etwa der wärmeplan steht längst
in zwölf Jahren sollen 80% der Bürger an
dem dann CO2-freien Fernwärmenetz hängen
die anderen über Nahwärme oder eigene
Wärmepumpen versorgt werden
es ist aber eine große Herausforderung
sowohl organisatorisch kapazitätsmäßig
wie auch finanziell wir gehen die Sache
sehr sportlich und und konstruktiv an
und wir sind alle Seiten sind Willens
das Ziel zu erreichen zur
Klimaneutralität im Jahr 2045 hat
Deutschland sich in international
bindenden Verträgen verpflichtet
und von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gehen wir
jetzt nach Schleswig-Holstein denn das
Bundesland gehört zu denen die auch
nicht warten sondern machen so gibt es
dort bereits seit rund anderthalb Jahren
die Pflicht zur kommunalen wärmeplanung
und damit einen schönen guten Abend dem
SPD Oberbürgermeister aus Kiel Ulf
Kempfer der auch der Präsident des
Verbands kommunaler Unternehmen ist
guten Abend nach Mainz Herr Kämpfer ist
das mit der kommunalen wärmeplanung für
die Kommunen wirklich so kompliziert wie
manche behaupten oder ist das alles
machbar wenn man nur will
ich glaube es ist kompliziert und es ist
machbar zugleich und das ganze muss auch
wirklich schnell gehen weil wir wie
gesagt ja in weniger zehnten
klimaneutral sein wollen in
Schleswig-Holstein sogar schon im Jahr
2040 wir haben ja Jahre Jahrzehnte bei
der wärmewende wenig gemacht und dann
müssen wir jetzt ein Schlag zulegen
Schlag zulegen sie haben auch gesagt das
Gesetz braucht es noch vor der
Sommerpause sicher für klare Ansagen
auch in Sachen Geld aber was braucht es
denn noch ihrer Meinung nach also
erstmal ist überhaupt dass dieses
wärmeplanungssystem kommt ist ein großer
Wurf wir haben noch die ein oder andere
Kritik daran heute ist jetzt der
endgültige Entwurf gekommen aber im
Prinzip ist es das genau was wir
brauchen wichtig ist dass es dann nicht
nur ein Plan wird sondern dass er auch
verbindlich umsetzbar ist also wirklich
ein scharfes Schwert damit die
Stadtwerke verbindlich das umsetzen
können wir haben Wünsche was die
Förderer angeht bisher sind dafür 3
Milliarden bis 26 eingeplant wir
brauchen eigentlich drei Milliarden
jedes Jahr und das wissen sie Jahrzehnte
nein wir haben noch ein paar Dinge was
sage ich mal die Anforderungen an die
Fernwärmenetze angeht da sollen wir
schon im Jahr
2030 zur Hälfte klimaneutral sein Moment
ist das im Durchschnitt 18 Prozent das
ist für einige Stadtwerke wahrscheinlich
zu ehrgeizig aber die Richtung stimmt
und es wir sind ja mittendrin schon im
Plan das ist ein sehr wertvolles
Instrument und zusammen mit dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz ist das sind das beides
die beiden Schlüssel zur wärmewende und
damit ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt
klimaneutral zu werden klar die
Infrastruktur ist ein riesen
Herausforderung auch um Abwärme dann
überhaupt nutzen zu können das ist ja
jetzt auch noch nicht überall möglich
und es braucht einen Überblick wer wie
Heiz dazu gibt es die Datensammlung da
sagt die CSU das sei heizungsspionage
allerdings wird das in Bayern per
Klimaschutz gesetzt längst gemacht
verstehen sie vielleicht dennoch an der
ein oder anderen Stelle die Bedenken der
Bürger was diese Datensammlung anbelangt
also ich verstehe die Unsicherheit und
die Bedenken der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
was sie kosten ange also was diese
Ernährung der Häuser wie wird das mit
den Energiepreisen da sind doch die
Bedenken da müssen wir jetzt sehr
schnell Klarheit schaffen durch die
Gesetze bei den Daten da haben wir auch
ein paar Punkte wo wir sagen das geht
auch ein bisschen einfacher aber von
wegen heizungsstasi heizungspranger das
ist wirklich gekühlter Quark das ist
überhaupt nicht das Thema wir sind mit
der Kommunikation mit Frau galwitz mit
Robert Habeck und wenn es sehr zufrieden
da hat sich jetzt auch eine neue
Offenheit entwickelt und deswegen
glauben wir so kompliziert und auch
politisch schwierig das ganze ist wir
wollen und wir können da jetzt glaube
ich sehr schnell zu Entscheidung kommen
damit alle die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
die Firmen die Stadtwerke die
Planungssicherheit haben auf die wir so
dringend warten und sagen Sie das nur
weil sie SPD Mann sind oder sind sie
wirklich so überzeugt in na es gibt
viele von Konflikte und sie haben die
Kommunikation angesprochen und die
Verunsicherung wie sie jetzt ist die
hätte so groß nicht sein müssen sie
wurde sicherlich von anderen geschirrt
und wir haben bei der Verzahnung zum
Beispiel jetzt von dem heizungsgesetz
also vom Gebäude Energiegesetz und von
der von der Werbeplanung der gibt schon
noch ein paar wichtige offene Punkte
also das ist alles nicht kritikfrei aber
wir sind uns in der grundsätzlichen
Zielrichtung ja einig mit der
Bundesregierung dass wir so schnell wie
möglich die wärmewende anpacken müssen
und da sind ist das wärmeplansgesetz
einfach ein ganz entscheidender
Schlüssel je schneller wir planen desto
schneller können wir umsetzen und das
wird schwierig genau interessanten Punkt
angesprochen und zwar die Reihenfolge
also kleine Städte die haben jetzt bis
2028 Zeit Großstädte bis 2026 als
BürgerInnen weiß ich aber spätestens
dann ob die Fernwärme beispielsweise
kommt zu mir was wenn ich vorher meine
Heizung austauschen muss da ist doch die
Reihenfolge nicht wirklich
durchdacht also aktuell greift erst das
heizungsgesetz und dann die kommunale
Planung das ergibt irgendwie keinen Sinn
wie soll man das denn jetzt lösen das
ist sicherlich der komplizierteste und
ja schwierigste Teil jetzt in den
nächsten Wochen dazu beraten ist das
gute ist wir haben jetzt ja beide
Gesetze im Entwurf das GEG und das
wärmeplanungsgesetz und da wird man an
einigen Stellen sicherlich noch bei den
Übergangsfristen bei den
härtefallklauseln was machen müssen ich
verstehe diese Kritik umgekehrt jetzt
bis Ende des Jahrzehnts zu warten bis
wir beim heizungsgesetz klar haben ich
glaube damit gibt man den Leuten auch
Steine statt Brot weil ja auch ist
falsch wäre jetzt Leute noch zu sehr in
fossile Heizungsanlagen zu pushen die
dann nachher auch nicht mehr bezahlbar
sind weil die Zertifikate und die Steuer
so hoch ist also das ist schon ein
komplizierter Teil
umso wichtiger ist dass da die
gordischen Knoten jetzt durchschlagen
werden dazu haben wir sehr konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht wenn man den folgt
sind wir feinen gute Übergangsfrist kann
eine Lösung sein sicherlich nicht für
die die neu bauen müssen zum Schluss
noch eine Frage sie setzen das ja bei
sich ganz gut um wie haben sie die
Bürger und Bürgerinnen eigentlich
mitgenommen also wir sind Kiel sind
Klimaschutz statt wir haben eine sehr
langwierige lang eingeübte
Kommunikationskultur reden schon länger
über wärmeplanung wir haben ein Modell
wir bis 2035 die Fernwärme klimaneutral
machen können und wir haben jetzt schon
ein sehr starkes Fernwärmenetz und
wollen das gerne ausbauen und da glaube
ich haben wir es geschafft glaube ich
auch für Vertrauen zu sorgen aber
trotzdem ist sie Unsicherheit auch in
Kiel groß umso wichtiger sind die
Förderprogramme die soziale Absicherung
und endlich endlich Planungssicherheit
das geplante Gesetz zur kommunalen
wärmeplanung soll dann ja zusammen mit
dem Gebäude Energiegesetz 2024 in Kraft
treten bis dahin wird bestimmt noch viel
geredet Herr Kämpfer vielen herzlichen
Dank für Ihre Zeit heute abend vielen
Dank auch Ihnen
und damit kommen wir jetzt zu einer
Geschichte die den Puls etwas höher
schlagen lässt vielleicht auch den des
Verteidigungsministers ehemalige
Kampfpiloten aus Deutschland sollen
aktive Kampfpiloten in China ausbilden
und zwar schon seit Jahren jetzt könnte
man meinen dass jemand nach dem
Ausscheiden aus dem Dienst machen kann
was er oder sie will dem ist aber nicht
so es gibt Regeln aber wer Regeln
aufstellt der muss sie auch prüfen
heikel am jobeinsatz in China ist
insbesondere das unter den deutschen
Ex-Soldaten auch ehemalige Eurofighter
Ausbilder sind die geheime Einsatz
Taktiken und Techniken der NATO kennen
Thomas Reichert über ein mögliches
Sicherheitsrisiko das über die deutschen
Grenzen hinausgeht
eigentlich will Verteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius in Singapur darüber
sprechen wie ein militärischer Konflikt
verhindert werden kann zwischen China
und dem Westen ein Problem dabei aber
hat er selbst mit dem Gepäck Recherchen
von ZDF frontal und Spiegel zeigen das
ehemalige Piloten der Luftwaffe nach
ihrem Ausscheiden ihr Fachwissen zu Geld
machten sie sollen chinesische
Militärpiloten trainiert haben gegen
Spitzen
einer von ihnen ist Peter S
offiziell wohnt er in einem Haus bei
Rostock aber er ist nicht da sein
Briefkasten ungelehrt
wir erreichen ihn telefonisch in China
wir würden gerne mit Ihnen sprechen über
ihre beratungsstätigkeit Ausbildungen in
China okay sie wissen schon wie spät wir
es haben
das ist uns nicht ganz klar
gerade ja
die Frage ob expiloten der Luftwaffe den
systemrivalen China möglicherweise
westliche militärgeheimnisse verraten
alarmiert in Berlin die
geheimdienstkontrolleure im Bundestag
also ich glaube für Staaten und landen
von Flugzeugen brauchen die Chinesen
keine extra Ausbilder sondern es geht
hier offensichtlich um Fachkenntnisse
das wäre in der Tat ein maximal
problematischer Vorgang und
stellt ein enormes Sicherheitsrisiko da
in China sind nach ZDF und
spiegelrecherchen weitere Luftwaffen
Piloten als Ausbilder der tätig ein
Dokument aus dem Jahr 2016 listet einige
von ihnen auf Alexander h ein
euro-fighter Ausbilder der KJ Ex Tornado
Pilot und eben Peters sie alle sind
demnach Luftfahrt Berater im Auftrag der
Firma Lohde technology mit Sitz in
Peking
die Firma soll in diesem etwas
heruntergekommenen Bürokomplex ihren
Sitz haben aber dort kennt sie angeblich
niemand
sicher ist der Mann hinter Lode ist so
bin ein spionendiensten Pekings 2016 in
den USA verurteilt dann ausgeliefert
nach China so bin hat zugegeben unter
anderem geheime Datensätze zur
militärtransportmaschine der USA der C17
gestohlen zu haben durch China braucht
mehr als das es ist sehr wichtig dass es
eben nicht nur darum geht Kampfjets
bauen zu können die hochqualitativ sind
sondern es geht auch darum dass man
Piloten braucht die diese eben auch
fliegen können und die dazu beitragen
können dass das sozusagen das teure
Gerät dass man angeschafft hat auch den
echten Nutzen erfüllt deutsche
Nachrichtendienste sind deshalb besorgt
dass die Piloten NATO Taktiken verraten
könnten die ich Ihnen nützlich sind für
einen Angriff auf Taiwan
Peters lässt mit seiner habe weder
Geheimnisse verraten noch eine
Arbeitsbeziehung zu so bin gehabt 2013
habe ihm die Bundeswehr die Ausbildung
von Piloten im Ausland erlaubt der
Verteidigungsminister wiederum kündigt
den Singapur Konsequenzen an jeder
Einzelfall muss geprüft werden das
müssen wir konnten werden wir konsequent
machen und alle Überschreitungen werden
geahndet das ist völlig eindeutig sein
Ministerium erklärt außerdem man wolle
mit den Nachrichtendiensten in Zukunft
Zitat aktiv die weitere Anwerbung von
Piloten verhindern
und wir haben es gerade gehört geäußert
hat sich der Verteidigungsminister zu
den Recherchen von ZDF frontal und
Spiegel in Singapur was er dort macht
Gundula damit beginnen jetzt deine
Nachrichten
anlässlich der Sicherheitskonferenz in
Singapur hat sich Pistorius dort für ein
stärkeres deutsches Engagement im
indopazifischen Raum ausgesprochen die
Region sei von zentraler Bedeutung für
den globalen Frieden diskutiert wird
auch über die andauernden Drohungen
Chinas gegenüber Taiwan das Peking als
Teil Chinas betrachtet und
wiedervereinen will eine Gesprächs bitte
von
US-Verteidigungsminister Austin dazu
wurde von chinesischer Seite abgelehnt
bei einem schweren Zugunglück im Osten
Indiens sind dutzende Menschen ums Leben
gekommen hunderte wurden verletzt als
ein Passagierzug entgleiste der genaue
Unfallhergang ist noch unklar insgesamt
sind zwei Personen und ein Güterzug
beteiligt die indische Regierung
investiert massiv in die Sicherheit der
Schienen trotzdem kommt es immer wieder
zu Eisenbahn Unfällen
die in Leipzig geplante
Solidaritätsdemonstration der
linksautonomen Szene bleibt untersagt
das Verwaltungsgericht Leipzig hat einen
Eilantrag gegen das Verbot
zurückgewiesen Begründung es sei mit
hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit von einem
unfriedlichen Verlauf auszugehen trotz
des Verbots bereitet sich die Polizei
mit einem Großaufgebot auf mögliche
Demonstrationen und Ausschreitungen vor
seit dem frühen Abend gehören Teile der
Stadt zu einem Kontrollbereich
bei den Ermittlungen zu den Explosionen
an den nordstream Pipelines in der
Ostsee hat es Ende Mai eine Durchsuchung
in Frankfurt an der Oder gegeben die
Bundesanwaltschaft teilte mit es sei die
Wohnung einer nicht Tatverdächtigen
Person gewesen offenbar der ehemaligen
Lebensgefährtin eines möglichen
Attentäters der auch einen ukrainischen
Pass haben soll es geht um den Abgleich
von dNA Spuren gefunden auf einer
Segelyacht die bei der Sprengung der
Pipelines eine Rolle gespielt haben soll
Russland setzt sein Bombardement der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt Kiew
ungewöhnlich heftig fort nach Angaben
der ukrainischen Armee sind 15
Marschflugkörper und 21 Kampfdrohnen auf
Kiew abgefeuert worden alle sein von der
Luftverteidigung abgefangen worden und
auch in der russischen Region Belgorod
dauern die Kämpfer an zwei Frauen sein
getötet worden erklärte der Gouverneur
der Region und machte die ukrainische
Armee für die Angriffe verantwortlich
erst kommt das Fressen dann kommt die
Moral lässt sich dieser Satz von
Berthold Brecht auch auf das Anwenden
was seit kurzem in der Europäischen
Union und Kommission für Aufregung sorgt
es geht um eine Liste mit Namen von
westlichen Unternehmen die in und mit
Russland weiter Geschäfte machen trotz
des russischen angriffskriegs und so
nennt die Ukraine die Liste die Sie ins
Netz gestellt hat auch die
internationalen Sponsoren des Krieges
unter ihnen übrigens auch ein deutsches
Unternehmen die Metro moralisch mag das
verwerflich sein es mag sogar dem Ruf
schaden doch was ist mit der Ukraine
selbst hat sie sich mit dem öffentlichen
Pranger einen Gefallen getan Florian
neuhahn über eine schwarze Liste die
auch Einfluss auf das elfte
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland haben
könnte
einmal zum Großeinkauf an den Stadtrand
von Moskau wir filmen normalen Alltag
vor einer metro-filiale einer von knapp
100 im ganzen Land Metro ist nämlich
geblieben anders als viele westliche
Firmen hat der deutsche Handelskonzern
das Land nach Beginn des russischen
Krieges nicht verlassen sein Name steht
deshalb auf einer brisanten Liste an der
Liste die die ukrainische Regierung ins
Netz gestellt hat
internationale Sponsoren des Krieges
heißt sie es ist eine Art moderner
Pranger im Netz
es gibt keine rechtlichen Konsequenzen
wenn eine Firma auf unserer Liste steht
es geht hier nur um moralische Fragen es
geht um die Reputation
gerade veröffentlicht sorgt die Liste
für massig Ärger auch hier beim jüngsten
Treffen der EU Außenminister in Brüssel
Ungarn blockiert weitere Sanktionen
gegen Russland weil die ungarische Bank
FTP auf der ukrainischen Liste steht
doch diesmal ist das Land mit einem
Ärger nicht allein auch Österreichs
Raiffeisenbank wird als Sponsor des
Krieges angeprangert auch Österreich ist
sauer ich verstehe die Emotionalität
auch der ukrainischen Freunde in dieser
Frage aber ich glaube einzelne
Unternehmen herauszugreifen und andere
nicht ist glaube ich nicht der richtige
Weg warum nur einzelne Firmen genannt
werden das begründet die ukrainische
Seite dem ZDF gegenüber mit ihren
Kapazitäten man prüfe jeden Fall einzeln
doch hat sich die Ukraine mit diesem
Pranger einen Gefallen getan und sind
westliche Firmen die in Russland
geblieben sind darunter dieser
französische Lebensmittelkonzern
wirklich Sponsoren des Krieges
natürlich ist jedes Unternehmen das in
Russland aktiv ist steuerpflichtig in
Russland und zahlt damit natürlich auch
in den russischen Staatshaushalt Steuern
ein es gab auch andere Probleme für
diese Unternehmen weil sie eben auch der
russischen Rechtsprechung unterliegen
dass sie beispielsweise teilweise
mithelfen mussten bei der Mobilisierung
von Soldaten für den russischen Angriff
wir fragen den Metro-Konzern was er zu
der Liste sagt vor der Kamera kein
Interview schriftlich heißt es Metro
habe Russlands Krieg mehrfach in aller
Deutlichkeit öffentlich verurteilt
außerdem an den Fokus auf die
Unterstützung der Ukraine gelegt etwa
mit vielen Spenden da erhalte man die
Aufnahme in die Liste für nicht
sachgerecht was die ukrainische Seite
nicht überzeugt
wir können uns bei der Metro für die
Unterstützung an die Ukraine nur
bedanken aber die Metro hat eben
indirekt auch diesen russischen Krieg
finanziert und das wiegt in unseren
Augen schwerer
Sponsoren des Krieges was der Ukraine
mit dieser Liste wieder einmal gelingt
den Westen vor sich her zu treiben
und jetzt schauen wir auf die
Finanzmärkte die weltweit erleichtert
sind weil in den USA der Zahlungsausfall
verhindert wurde Gundula ja nach dem
Repräsentantenhaus hat auch der US-Senat
der Kompromisslösung zugestimmt damit
wird die Obergrenze der US-Schulden
vorerst ausgesetzt und nicht mehr nur
angehoben Valerie Haller in Frankfurt
die Finanzmärkte reagierten also
erleichtert es gibt allerdings auch ein
aber ja also sie reagiert eine
erleichtert weil damit eine lange
Zitterpartie auch für die die
Finanzmärkte sehr beunruhigt hat der
Kompromiss kam ja auch kurz vor knapp
ohne Einigung wäre der US-Regierung
schon in wenigen Tagen das Geld
ausgegangen mit potentiell
katastrophalen Folgen für die
amerikanische und die Weltwirtschaft das
hätte eine globale Finanzkrise auslösen
können damit ist das Thema aber nicht
vom Tisch sondern nur auf 20 25
verschoben mal wieder die Amerikaner
haben die Schulden Obergrenze in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten schon dutzende
Male angehoben und das zeigt ein ganz
grundsätzliches Problem dass die USA
schon lange weit über ihre Verhältnisse
leben Rating-Agenturen beugen das
äußerst kritisch Ende offen der
Wochenbilanz des DAX hat die Entwicklung
in den USA auf jeden Fall gut getan ja
der Schuldenstreit hat Anleger viele
Nerven gekostet entsprechend positiv
reagierte der Aktienmarkt heute der DAX
knackt die 16.000 Punkte und beendet den
Tag mit einem Plus von fast 200 Punkten
ja und die ist nächste Woche weitergeht
wird auch davon abhängen wie Aktionäre
die weitere Zinsentwicklung einschätzen
dass die Zinsen vermutlich bald wieder
steigen haben sie heute scheinbar
weitgehend ausgeblendet vielen Dank
valerina Frankfurt
im Tarifkonflikt mit der Deutschen Bahn
verzichtet die Gewerkschaft EVG vorerst
auf neue Warnstreiks Anfang kommender
Woche soll es neue Gespräche zwischen
den Tarifparteien geben die Bahn hatte
weitere Verhandlungen zunächst abgelehnt
hofft jetzt aber auf
Kompromissvorschläge der Gewerkschaft
eine Personalie aus der
Fußball-Bundesliga nach nur einem Jahr
trennt sich Borussia Mönchengladbach von
Trainer Daniel Farke Folge einer
schwachen Saison die Gladbach erneut nur
auf Rang zehn beendete Parkes Vertrag
lief eigentlich noch zwei Jahre
die digitalminister der EU haben in
Luxemburg über den Umgang mit
künstlicher Intelligenz beraten das Ziel
ein EU-Gesetz zur Kontrolle von KI dabei
sprach sich der für Deutschland
zuständige Minister Wissing für eine
maßvolle Regulierung der Technologie in
der EU aus es brauche transparente
Regeln um die Chancen vertrauenswürdiger
KI zu nutzen zu den Risiken später im
heute journal Update ein Gespräch mit
einer Fachfrau vom deutschen Ethikrat
wenn sie könnten würden sie zum Mars
fliegen gut die Frage stellt sich Ihnen
und mir nicht wirklich einfach wegen der
Kosten vor über 20 Jahren hat sich diese
Frage aber die ESA gestellt die
europäische Weltraumorganisation hat sie
mit ja beantwortet und vor genau 20
Jahren ging es dann los die erste
europäische Mission zum Nachbarplaneten
startete und ist bis heute am Start der
marsexpress liefert unter anderem Daten
zur Atmosphäre des roten Planeten
erforscht seine Oberfläche und blickt
auch darunter wo Hinweise auf Wasser
entdeckt worden über eine faszinierende
Mission die viel länger dauert als
gedacht
so war der Mars noch nie zu sehen
Wissenschaftler haben 90 Einzelbilder
der hochauflösenden Kamera der Sonde
mars-express zu dieser Detail genauen
Ansicht unseres roten Nachbarplaneten
zusammengesetzt
man kann anhand dieser Bilder
Berechnungen anstellen wie viel
Vulkanismus da war wie viel Wasser da
mal war wie viel Eis da jetzt noch
herrscht wann das alles stattgefunden
hat und das sind große wissenschaftliche
Erkenntnisse die nur mit diesen
Kameraden möglich waren
vor 20 Jahren der erfolgreiche Start der
ersten europäischen maßmission unter
großen Jubel die eigentlich nur auf zwei
Jahre angelegt war
James Gottfried steuert die Sonde
marsexpress hier im Kontrollzentrum der
ESA in Darmstadt seit 14 Jahren und ist
stolz
es gab eine ganze Reihe
Herausforderungen in all den Jahren es
war immer wieder knapp und wir hätten
die Sonde fast verloren
die Sonde ging nicht verloren und
liefert unermüdlich Daten und Bilder
fast der gesamte Maß ist inzwischen
dreidimensional und in Farbe erfasst
besonders wichtig der Nachweis von
Wasser Eiskappen an den Polen und
riesige ausgetrocknete Flussbetten und
unter der Oberfläche vermuten die
Forscher große Mengen an flüssigem
Wasser das ist natürlich die
Voraussetzungen für Leben und danach
suchen wir natürlich ob wir wirklich die
einzigen sind in diesem Weltall oder ob
es eventuell irgendwelche Lebensformen
auf anderen Planeten auch geben könnte
doch bei allen Erfolgen die landeeinheit
von Mars Express Biegel 2 ging verloren
auch die andere aktuell noch laufende
maßmission der ESA Exo Mars konnte ihr
Landegerät nicht erfolgreich zum Mars
bringen
ein neuer Versuch einen Rover am Zielort
abzusetzen der auch tief in die Erde
bohren kann verzögert sich da die
Mission ursprünglich eine Zusammenarbeit
mit der russischen Weltraumagentur war
die Kooperation wurde wegen Russlands
Krieg in der Ukraine beendet doch es
gibt ambitionierte Zukunftspläne
gemeinsam mit der NASA sollen Proben
sogar zurück zur Erde gebracht werden
und könnten in absehbarer Zeit sogar
Menschen zum Mars fliegen
[Musik]
Menschen zu Maß zu bringen ist in der
Tat ein Fernziel es fällt mir schwer da
jetzt in Zeithorizont zu geben denn es
sind noch einige technologische Hürden
zu bewältigen insofern rechne ich nicht
vor Mitte des nächsten Jahrzehnts
tatsächlich mit so einer Mission
so lange geht die unbemannte Forschung
vor Ort weiter marsexpress wird auf Kurs
um den Mars bleiben voraussichtlich bis
2026 oder sogar länger
faszinierend oder ja wunderbar mit dem
nächsten Jahrzehnts ist quasi wie du
gerade geschrieben hast übermorgen okay
nicht übermorgen geht es heute Nacht
noch mal weiter
Journal Update mit wolfschmiesen und
morgen sind dann hier Christian Sievers
und Hanna Zimmermann für Sie da das war
es von uns machen sie es gut wo auch
immer sie sind tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
ja guten Abend mit dem Temperatur Trend
hier von Köln möchte ich Ihnen mal
zeigen wie groß der
Temperaturunterschied im Moment zwischen
Tag und Nacht ist das sind Teil 10 Grad
oder mehr als 10 Grad Unterschied und
zustande kommt das dadurch dass dieses
Tief hier recht kühle Luft aus dem
Norden bis in Richtung Polen
vorangebracht hat und in Kombination mit
unserem stabilen hoch hier liegen wir in
einer nordöstlichen Strömung die genau
diese kühlere und trockenere Luft zu uns
transportiert und wenn dann wie heute
nach der Himmel doch meist klar ist dann
geht es hinab mit den Temperaturen im
Westen und im Süden bleiben wir in den
Städten meist zweistellig im Nordosten
kann es morgen früh aber bis zu drei
Grad kalt werden inklusive Bodenfrost
tagsüber ist das dann aber anders unter
dem Hochdruck Einfluss kann sich die
trockene Luft schnell erwärmen und zwar
auf 17 Grad an der Nordseeküste und 27
Grad am Oberrhein große
Temperaturunterschiede im Moment also
nicht nur zwischen den frühen und den
Nachmittagsstunden sondern auch zwischen
Nord und Süd der Tag startet mit viel
Sonne und harmlosen Wolken vor allem im
Norden und im Südosten es gibt einen
lebhaften Ostwind nachmittags werden die
Quellwolken im Süden aber wieder dichter
und die Schauer und Gewitter über dem
Südschwarzwald und den Alpen sind
wahrscheinlicher als noch heute und die
können dann im Verlauf der nächsten Tage
auch in Deutschland mal etwas nördlicher
ausgreifen ähm der Nordsee sind die
Wolken bisschen hartnäckiger für die
allermeisten gibt es aber sommerlichen
Sonnenschein und Wärme bis 28 Grad
tschüss